Ebenezer Essoka
Ebenezer: Well absolutely, I believe African
continent would benefit from the event. Yes
it's look at it in South Africa. I have been
in South Africa now for some time. I know
it's seen increased investments in South Africa.
We've seen investment in infrastructure transform
the landscape of this country. And I believe
the more people who come to South Africa for
the workshop, the more we create a positive
life after the World Cup Events in South Africa,
more companies benefit from that and with
that in mind, there really is a possibility
that those companies will now make a positive
ability to flow through to other countries
in the continent and thus create a positive
environment for the entire continent of Africa.
So welcome everybody to the continent of Africa
via South Africa for the World Cup.